Imagine two universes.
In one of these universes,
life flourishes on nearly
every planet you can encounter.
Floating in the atmosphere,
swimming in the seas,
lounging on the beaches.
Life in every body form and size
you can imagine.
Now imagine the other universe
where life is nowhere to be found.
Stars collide, galaxies explode,
meteorites crash, asteroids everywhere.
A ton of action, but no life.
Let me ask you this.
Which one of these universes
is more interesting to you?
Which one has more value?
So today I want to take you to a journey
to explore and understand
the origin of life,
the future and where it is headed
and an ethical dilemma
that may arise from understanding this.
First things first, Earth was formed
4.5 billion years ago.
Life happened fairly quickly,
within the first
few hundred million years.
So that's very fast.
Think about that next time
you feel like you're aging too fast.
(Laughter)
You're not. You're fine.
And here is how life works.
Life is a form of chemistry.
A form of chemistry
that explores solutions
in response to the problems
in its own immediate chemical environment.
Life is a form of chemistry
that retains a memory of these solutions
over billions of years.
And life's first solution
was quite the trick:
copy itself.
This is astounding.
We would not be standing here today
if other tricks didn't follow,
like how to use water
as a source of electrons
or how to use
the nitrogen in the atmosphere
or how to chew on sunlight.
This is remarkable.
I am chemistry that explores.
I am chemistry that defies degradation,
and I am chemistry that remembers.
I am a tiny part of an unbroken
four-billion-year-old heritage,
a four-billion-year-old linkage.
Life makes our planet
an incredibly exotic place
compared to the rest
of the known universe.
This is the only place
that it is known to exist.
In fact, you can study physics
or chemistry or geology
anywhere else in the universe.
But this is the only place
where you can study biology.
Well, I happen to be a biologist
on the only planet
where you can be a biologist
in the entire universe.
(Laughter)
And that makes my job
very, very special, right?
Because our planet
offers an incredible opportunity
to explore its own origins
and understand how chemistry
converted itself into an agent
capable of responding to its environment
and stimulating itself
in response to this.
In the past 10 years,
there has been remarkable innovations
in our understanding of origin of life.
I lead a research laboratory,
and we are using statistics
and mathematical models
and evolutionary systems
and infer the sequences of ancient DNA
that existed billions of years ago.
We then synthesize
these ancient DNA molecules
and engineer them inside organisms.
For the first time,
we are able to activate molecules
that existed billions of years ago
to understand and capture
what happened back then.
We also stimulate and simulate
ancient environments in the lab
to understand the ingredients
by creating them
from water, air and rocks.
This means accessing
and obtaining chemistry
that is novel.
This means the ability
to drive chemical reactions
so that they can create chemistry
that organizes itself.
This means having chemistry in hand
that may act lifelike.
This is really remarkable.
So we might wonder:
What do we do when we have
this knowledge in our hands?
This may mean that
we would be able to connect the dots
between nonliving and living
and understand how chemistry
is translating and transforming
and transitioning
into a lifelike behavior.
This may mean that we would be able
to obtain the recipe of life, if you will,
and having this recipe
would enable us to connect the dots
between these two states
of living and nonliving.
This may enable us to look
at the particular environments
and know how far along
is that particular environment
from its own unique chemical revolution.
We might be able to study
different planets and moons
and assess them,
and assess their chemistry,
and know how far along they are
from giving birth to life.
And we may be able
to guide our telescopes in the vast sky
in more guided ways
in our pursuit
of finding life in the universe.
We might also ask ourselves:
What can we do with this knowledge?
What if you weren't only assessing?
What if we were also interacting
and engaging with these planets and moons?
What if we were able to seed life
across the billions of planets
in the galaxy?
This would not be
seeding them with Earth life.
This wouldn't be engineering
an Earth organism
and preadapting them,
and preconditioning them
in a way that they exist and survive
in this other planetary body.
No.
This this wouldn't be terraforming,
altering the environment
of this other planet,
so that whatever we ship there makes it.
No.
This would be about empowering
and not colonizing these environments.
This would be about letting them
explore their own unique chemistry
to express their own unique reactions
by providing them the missing ingredients.
This wouldn't be
about sending them some life
so that we are genetically related
or something that is familiar to us.
This would be enabling them to do
what perhaps they were supposed to do
or meant to do all along,
but they were lacking
and missing ingredients.
And not lacking in the sense
that they themselves
were lacking something important,
in the sense that
they weren't lacking, right?
But what if we were able
to send the spice?
The secret sauce.
Give it a little nudge.
For it to react
with whatever is already present
in this planetary body
so that life is sparked,
in conjunction and agreement
with the own history and journey
and origin of this own planetary body,
without our meddling,
without our direction,
without anything that we do
to direct this in any way.
This would be kickstarting a process
that may unfold itself
over thousands or millions of years
into the future.
But should we do it?
This is an extraordinary proposition.
And it brings up an extraordinary dilemma
about what it means to be alive.
Does life, as a chemical system
capable of formulating,
and in some cases answering, questions
about its own existence,
have a responsibility
or should have a prohibition
against sponsoring more life
across the universe?
Do we do this just because we could?
And what is the ethical difference
and is there any ethical difference
between spreading a particular Earth life
versus spreading a potential of life
across the galaxy?
And where does this difference lie?
So I really tried
to bring you answers today,
and I don't have any.
But I see the facts
shaping in front of me.
A universe full with life is interesting
because having a solution
in hand has value, right?
But perhaps the spontaneity
and unpredictability of discovering
novel chemistries and novel life forms
is also interesting
and has its own unique merits.
But do we get to set course
and let natural evolution
discover its own local environments
wherever it might be in the cosmos?
An empty universe in this regard, I think,
can be viewed as an wide open palette
for solutions waiting to be discovered.
But should we do it just because we can?
It is very important to keep in mind
that Earth is our only home,
and it's a good planet.
And you know the saying:
“Good planets are hard to find.”
(Laughter)
I know that, I've been looking for one.
I'll let you know when I find a good one.
Exploring the origins may allow us
to truly understand life around us,
and perhaps an exercise like this
may encourage us
to truly appreciate and understand
how life emerged in the first place.
I really think that in order for us
to understand the biology
and life around us,
we really need to understand
how life happened to this planet
in the first place.
I really, really believe in this.
I will dedicate my life to do this.
And before I leave to do that,
back to my lab that I missed very much,
let me ask you again:
A universe that is empty
and one with a lot of life.
Which one of this
is more interesting to you?
Thank you. Thank you very much.
Teşekkürler.
(Applause)